هنا وصلنا الى هذا المنزل الذي بداخله
عائله كامله من الفلسطينيين استشهدوا وهم
باتوا على ما يبدو متحللين تماما في هذه
المنطقه التي كانت بها القوات الاسرائيليه
ما يقارب من العشره شهداء هنا في هذه
الغرفه
الصغيره قتلتهم ايضا القوات الاسرائيليه
بدم بارد هنا حسب ما يقول شهود العيان ب
فيكم شهداء موجودين هنا في كمان شهيد ه
كمان مرنا هنا واطلع مصنع سنيم مصنع سيم
كيف فيه ومصنع ابو عمره ومصنع مش عارف مين
صحيح هذا كل ضمار حكايه ماليه غير الله
حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل بس هذا اللي بنقدر
نقول عليه في هذه الاثناء انفجار كبير
يحدث في هذه المنطقه القوات الاسرائيليه
تقوم بنسف عدد من منازل المواطنين داخل
مخيم المغازي وسط
القطاع وهذا هو مدخل منطقه حي المصدر
الواقع بالقرب من شار شار صلاح الدين شارع
صلاح الدين الرئيسي وهذه المنشات الصناعيه
باتت دمارا كبيرا يحل بها جراء الغارات
الاسرائيليه والقصف الاسرائيلي العنيف
خلال الايام الماضيه القوات الاسرائيليه
المتوغلة
من هنا ولكن احدثت دمارا كبيرا في
الممتلكات وايضا في البنيه التحتيه في هذه
المنطقه حتى سيارات الاسعاف لم تستطع
الوصول الى جثامين الشهداء المتحلله منذ
ايام بعد انسحاب القوات الاسرائيليه خلال
الساعات الماضيه من هذه المنطقه اشرف ابو
عمره لقناه الجزيره وسط قطاع غزه